there's one more important non line
integrand that ends up on a log function
you shouldn't matter before but you
probably have none too many questions on
it does he remember what it is something
where if I integrate it in he is not a
log but it's going to equal a long
something over here and it's not like
either of it okay all right let me ask
you this what's the integral of cos
integral of cos it's too early in the
morning I brain doesn't work with
positivity i differentiate something
it'll give because the answer is so just
normal sign what's it close to okay fine
it's a great sign all right here we go
yeah I could say minus cos okay so then
when you integrate tan that's let's try
it out right someone says I heard I
heard a few people say sex but let's
just Kim I just give to go why not you
know what is this this is actually one
over cos squared isn't it right CPM for
shaping here it's okay well the great
Dima integration is you can always find
out whether you're right just by
differentiating right so let's give it a
shot differentiate one over cause that's
where what do you get I suppose I could
write that as cos x to the power of
minus 2 right let's see if you're so
excited the derivative all right so
chain rule differentiate the inside
you'll get a minus sine X differentiate
the outside that's a minus 2 that'll
come out the front then the power
juices by one this has a double negative
so I'm just going to get it sine X on
Klaus this isn't looking promising
people ok what did we do wrong we didn't
integrate at all this is the derivative
of tan the derivative of tan is sex
square ok so this is not a good rabbit
shell to go down all right let's try and
write this in a form that will make it a
little easier for us though to be honest
I'd be giving you clues all day ok tan
tan tan is a shortcut isn't it it's sign
odd guys now just like here we started
with this didn't we ok he art I don't
quite have F dash on earth do I I'm
pretty close but I'm not there so we
multiply by closet to get their dinner
we now here I don't have f dash on earth
because sine is not the root of the
cause what is the derivative cause it's
negative sign isn't it which is what we
recognize here so in order to get a
minus sign of the top you can't just put
minus signs anywhere you like you've got
to put one out the front that's what we
did with the concert over there it's too
just another constant although my cards
oops why am I plussing see sorry guys ok
our uniform we can use now that's f dash
on an F there's a minus sign just sort
of hanging around like an awkward 3rd
wheelin on the front then or in the form
that we need this is log of F which is
in this case prize right so this is
probably the last important
dawn Lord integrand that ends up on a
loan function okay these three you
really have to wrap your head around
I'll admit this one doesn't come up all
that often but they'll expect you to
know it and they'll expect you to get it
right because it's on the table standard
integrals okay so if you see it don't
panic go back and you'll see the result
that it leads to it's not enough to be
us where it starts getting confusing is
when you start looking again inverse
trig and the image of that look very
very similar but that's kind of why you
get given this table set up any
questions yeah like when you integrate
and get a little value yep you with
absolute value ah good right so some of
you are saying let's let's start with
just a simple one shall we I'm too
excited let's start with it so show me
they've seen really takes a cheering
well okay if you do love whenever X is
built log X some of you all seen this
the integral of 1 over X respect to X is
modelled absolute value of x ok now
let's just pause for a second and think
about why the important thing is the
poison to be honest because a lot of
people will just write this down blindly
and then like look why is that true the
textbook centage takes forecast to be
true which sort of a map to iran it on
wikipedia so therefore you know um
doesn't really say much about a
mathematical understanding absolute
value tricky you have to be careful with
them why might you stick in an absolute
value here where there's no kind of
theories suggesting that you might need
absolutely that why we do it
okay right said the log function there
is actually something that gives us a
clue the Lord function doesn't have the
same domain as whatever X right what's
the domain of one of us was it look like
it's this guy isn't it okay what's its
domain let's put the wall realities of X
SATs 40 that's what you're asking
Turner's whereas log X just looks like
this so its domain is positive x yeah
sure what might we stick this to you
okay it has to do with a specific kind
of question right because this is still
a true saving this is still true okay
without the absolute value story the
reason you bring negative values in is
if you're trying to work out something
like for way to go an area okay now if
you're calculating that area see you
have to be careful we asses into it if
you're calculating the area should you
get a positive or negative if you're
calculating the area it must be positive
because area just like length is a it
just it only takes a positive value but
if you're evaluating the integral over
there all you're doing is evaluate
integral safe from minus 2 so minus 1
what should you get positive or negative
these you should get a negative because
it's beneath the axis okay so therefore
look at this guy think about it okay
suppose I want to turn a tablespace
suppose I wanted to integrate whatever X
what boundaries I just give you minus 2
minus 1
okay now what would happen if I just
blindly Chuck didn't log off absolute
value X from lightest to 2-1 what will
happen is it gonna work out because I'm
expecting a negative on our time let's
give you go shall we I prune all about
careful which one's the upper bound
minus one could bigger isn't it I know
the number looks to the value look speak
up but this one is higher right so I say
log of absolute value minus 1 now 1
minus log of absolute value of minus 2
ok what's the Lord of Australia minus 1
that's the log of 1 minus the log of 2
sorry that's not helpful is it that's
enough ok what's a longer one it's just
0 is it by this this is point 693 blah
blah something right whatever that is so
therefore what are we got ok so this is
this is good we've got the negative that
we expected okay but now if I'm
interpreting this in terms of area I
have to say therefore the area is log 2
units square ok you've got to say that
now I know people like ma there's
masters doing that physics thing it's
just like it's after write sentences
this is rubbish this is why I did mats
out in a fright sentences you have to do
that I'll tell you why what's the
alternative to writing the system I'll
tell you what the alternative is because
I've seen it written down so many times
ok people say oh it's fine is more to
but I have an area so they say that's
log 2 units squared and a part of my
soul dies every time ok you cannot just
turn a negative into a positive because
because you wanted to ok so please
please don't do that because it's not
true right write a sentence you've
formed an appropriate integral that's
important
okay if you wanted to avoid the sentence
if you so definitely want to do that um
I suppose you see I'm thinking about
whether what you can do is format a
different integral here okay and you can
reason that it's it's an equivalent
integral but see then the problem is you
have to reason so you got to write it
this anyway ah so moral story is get to
hear that's the correct answer that's
what the definition was equal to if you
asked to work out the area right
something the same okay now by the way
that was just talking about this one
okay you can see that it's autumn
extends as you go through be careful
whatever X minus 1 it no longer shares
the same domain as one of wrecks how
does it stem in different whatever X
minus 1 it's moved over where's it moved
one unit to the right okay and you can
draw it you can see the asymptotes been
different so therefore this is going to
be a log of absolute value X minus 1 but
the domain is different for the values
the changeover so you have to be careful
but that's what you use this for all
right don't just blindly put in an
absolute values whenever you feel like
it okay if I saw this question I would
like that nothing to do with area okay
we've really absolute value because it
actually has an effect fun it definitely
is that make sense okay sorry wait only
hopefully not it just now let me try and
save one more time the reason why the
absolute value is important white
becomes significant is when you want to
put in negative values that's where it
starts to break down if you don't have
the absolute value okay because if I
didn't have the absolute value here you
did you know you calculate put okay so
if there aren't that's that's why you
see if there's no bounds you shouldn't
have to bring in an absolute value
because you're never going to have to
put in negative numbers okay so you
bring the absolute value because
negative numbers might be issued
when you have a definite ok